hello and welcome to my
playlist of molecular biology explained
in three minutes
where i explain the concept of molecular
biology in less than three minutes or so
if you haven't yet subscribed the
channel hit that subscribe button
today we'll talk about random
amplification of polymorphic dna
or otherwise known as rapd sometimes
it's also pronounced as a rapid
so this is a pcr based technique and
here is a quick highlights
for rapd it's a pcr based technique
and for rapd several arbitrary short
primers
which are ranging from 8 to 12
nucleotides are used and no
prior knowledge of a dna sequence is
required to perform this technique
now in this video we'll talk about the
principle
the applications and the limitations of
this particular technique
so as we have mentioned earlier that
rapd is a polymerase chain reaction
based technique
but it is slightly different from the
pcr because the segments
that are amplified are kind of random so
here is a normal pcr we use a specific
primer
to amplify a specific portion of the dna
but in case of rapd things are different
the amplification is random and several
different
length of products are generated
now let us try to understand this thing
in a bit more details
so here is the pcr machine and we are
performing a rapid reaction
as the temperature rise to 95 degree
centigrade there would be denaturation
of the strands
and here are our rapd primers which are
annealed
at 55 degrees centigrade let's say now
these primers which are
situated close enough they would
result in amplification now the primers
which are situated far apart
roughly greater than two kilo base pairs
then there would be no amplification
so different lengths of a pcr product
would be generated eventually let's try
to contextualize this aspect
so let's say we have a crime scene an
rfpd is a robust method
which can be used to differentiate
between genetically distinct individuals
so this dna is obtained from a crime
scene and we have two prime suspect so
what we are going to do
we are going to perform rapd from these
dna sequence
next we are going to isolate dna from
suspect 1
and suspect 2 and perform rapd from
their dna
as well now we are going to compare
their rapd profiles
now in this particular example the rapd
profile
obtained from crime scene dna matches
with
the dna rapd result from suspect
2. that means possibly suspect 2
is the convict so this is a very
uh general example
how rapd could be used but these kind of
methods are not really used these days
now there are several applications of
rapd
like in forensic sciences just we have
mentioned
about it it could be used in gene
mapping
crop variety identification or even in
microbial genetics
but these days rfpd is not that much
used
why is so there are several advantages
of rapd
like we don't need to have any prior
information about
dna sequences it can
really analyze genetic diversity of
individual
with a set of random primers it can be
done with very low amount of dna as well
but despite of these advantages there
are lots and lots of disadvantage
very low reproducibility nearly
all the rfpd markers are dominant so it
is impossible to determine
heterozygous versus homozygous
and lastly mismatch between primers and
the templates can result
in a total absence of pcr product as
well as
some kind of decreased amount of product
so the results could be sometimes
really confusing and hard to interpret
due to all of these reason rapd is not a
great technique to do
all of these biological
classification work now
in this particular era of high
throughput
sequencing rapd and its application it's
kind of
questionable but anyway in 1990
rapd was the technique so i hope you
enjoyed this video
if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can watch
all my playlist in my channel it would
be highly beneficial for you you can
follow me
in instagram or in facebook and see you
in the next video do let me know in the
comment whether it was useful
or not if you have a suggestion do let
me know in the comment thank you